da wird herzlich willkommen meine lieben
freunde zum heutigen kontakt wo ich euch
mal eine woche meinem leben zeigen
wollte ihn hat das ganze jahr von einem
typischen tag in seinem leben gemacht
bei mir ist es allerdings ein bisschen
anders ich wollte ich einfach mal eine
woche in meinem leben zeigen müsste aber
differenzieren das ist keine typische
woche meinem leben ist sondern nicht
einfach ihnen eine woche raus gegriffen
hat das ist jetzt nicht so viel passiert
ist es eine ganz es ist wirklich eine
relativ normale woche bei mir nahezu
aber ich würde sagen ich einfach jeden
tag durch und ich habe jeden tag ein
bisschen was gefilmt was ich da gemacht
habe und viel spaß eine woche beginnt
mit montag also würde ich sagen gefangen
wie rauchende montag an und zwar war ich
am montag den ganzen tag in der
thier-galerie dortmund mit einer
freundin mit einer freundin und wir
haben dann da einfach so ein bisschen
was eingekauft ich bin eigentlich nur
mit der intentionen gefahren t shirt
umtausch das nicht geklappt hat und mir
tolle iphone hülle zu kaufen was nur so
halb geklappt also die wir eigentlich
schon cool aus sein iphone das ist ein
bisschen spyder app die stars aber das
ist so eine coole hülle irgendwie von
original apple die jetzt ein bisschen
rum weil es nicht die habe ich wieder
gekauft und alles was ihnen gefällt hat
seht ihr jetzt
wo immer wir
am dienstag musste ich um sieben uhr
morgens aufstehen weil ich blut und urin
bei seinem arzt abgeben musste weil der
ihn kontrollieren wollte auch mit mir
alles in ordnung ist also blutwerte alle
möglichen werte dann bin ich von da aus
weiter zu einem anderen arzt gefahren
der irgendwie mich abgehakt hat und so
geguckt habe ob ich irgendwas so habe
weil ich ja schon seit vier wochen noch
mal so ein bisschen verschnupft bin und
das kann er keine normale allergie
irgendwie sein und ich hatte jetzt ein
bisschen als ist etwas ernstes ist bin
dazu zwei verschiedenen ärzten gefahren
und hab mir dann bei marktkauf noch was
zu essen gekauft und war abends noch
laufen und da hab ich auch das gefühl
dass sie jetzt
es ist jetzt gerade im autos ist gerade
halb zwölf ärzten beinlich gräser und
pollen allergie hat und das ist jetzt
genau wie die voll
jahreszeit wo das am krassesten ist
deswegen habe ich derzeit immer seit
vier wochen lange schon stopfen und
alles möglich aber ich glaube der zweite
in den herzen meine mutter und ich sie
genauso und ich hab mir gedacht dass er
eine komplette zusammenfassung der woche
in diesem kontaktiert zeige ich euch
einfach immer wenn ich irgendwo an
anderen orten bin jetzt stellen wir gab
beim marktkauf und ich im auto cool
ich glaube ich muss hier unter ihren job
immer noch passieren was sie nicht will
dass die sonne so schön untergehen
jedem sei aber ganz schön krass dass ich
mir noch ein bisschen die sonne am
mittwoch einfach ein tag wo nahezu gar
nichts passiert ist ich habe mein wecker
nicht gehört und habe deswegen einfach
mal bis 2 uhr geschlafen hab dann ihm
drei uhr gegessen bei den gästen auf dem
sofa dann alles einfach gedacht ok
kommen wie es jetzt gemacht die sonne
geht langsam unter ich muss halt nur
irgendwas machen deswegen bin ich nach
draußen gegangen bin joggen gegangen und
bin immer noch ein bisschen auto
gefahren und da hat 1live mir so richtig
kriege stories erzielt so von keine
ahnung was sie ja hier da ist jetzt
einer gestorben und alles möglich so
creepy stories und das hatte ich dann
nicht fallen 86 manier wenn das eis aber
dass ihr alles jetzt unterlagen am
donnerstag
ich weiß nicht irgendwelches gestern
gemacht das hat was
schöniger sollte man halt das hat was
das ist cool wenn man so spät abends
sorgen geht wenn sie die sondern schon
so ist es gerade 10 uhr und ich habe
karten kleinen igel getroffen hab den
paddington genannt petting empfinde ich
jetzt werde ich schöner name
so würde ich zwar nicht mein kind nennen
aber ein hund oder so
naja jedenfalls hier seht ihr mann der
igel ein bild davon eingeblendet alle
die mir auf instagram folgen angesehen
ich find auto und ein live spiel zu
horrorgeschichten ab
das ist voll krass die machen einfach so
über geschichten und ließen das fordert
sicherheitsdienst in mein vater liegt da
schon hier in halle 3 ist nach du dich
also ich habe angst bahnbau machten die
so was meine fresse
damit fahre ich außerdem noch auf dem
achtzehnten geburtstag von einer
freundin und da war ich dann um halb
sechs oder irgendwann zu hause und hab
dann am nächsten tag dementsprechend bis
2 uhr wieder geschlafen weil man ganz
der schlafrhythmus allgemein seit ich
hab so ein bisschen
ich musste den ganzen schlaf nach neun
jahren in denen ich wenig geschlafen
baby nachholen und dann bin ich dann
essen gefahren ins all access ist ein
burger restaurant was ist hier so
übergibt daran in bielefeld und dann hab
ich da meinen london trip geplant weil
ich ja am montag also morgen nach london
fliegen werde verein sagt er wenn ich
auch richtig viel filmen und wie wir das
geplant haben und alles ist eigentlich
sehr wenig was ich da gefilmt habe da
habe ich aber noch ein bisschen was
angekündigt vorher das seht ihr jetzt
mal am freitag ist gar nichts passiert
da habe ich wirklich nichts gemacht habe
ich nur videos produziert und zum paar
sachen geplant unsere besprechung
gemacht zum beispiel beim finanzamt war
ich alles mögliche aber am samstag ist
eine menge passiert und zwar am samstag
bin ich morgens erst nach köln gefahren
habe mir gefrühstückt mann am piano und
dann sind wir weiter gefahren zum
nürburgring weil er das 24 stunden
rennen war dass ich ein paar sachen
gefilmt noch so ein paar fotos gemacht
und die seht ihr jetzt alle eingeblendet
hamburg hamburgs
aha
zeigen
h
aha
verfolgt
hi
hh
monika
hat
a
und dann würde ich auch sagen was es von
einer woche in meinem leben es war
wirklich noch eine woche die ich jetzt
einfach mal raus geblickt aber in einer
anderen woche beispielsweise der
nächsten woche werden wir sehr oft
grillen wir werden fußball gucken ich
würde nach bulgarien fliegen und die
wird nach london fliegen
also das ist der wiederum woche die
komplett anders aus wer sie könnte sich
sagen dass er jede woche so aussieht
dass ich dann verklagen da hinfahren und
dann unter einem arzttermin ab so ist
das natürlich nicht gemeint sein dass
richtigen eine woche meinem leben
rausgepickt ich hoffe ich jetzt gefallen
wenn sich gefallen lassen positive werte
oder außerdem bitten dass eine positive
bewertung damit ihr wollte sich öfter
wir endlich das mach ich bin jetzt seit
man diese sonntag gebunden weil da er
konnte am sonntag kommt aber ich erlebe
teilweise echt viele sachen wie
beispielsweise dieses nürburgring alles
hätte ich alles zusammen schon einige
praktiken und damit ich dann einfach
mehr räder vieles machen kann was haltet
ihr davon schrecklichen kommentare uns
schauen